[Music]
great transition to your good friend
Linda Sarsour oh let's start sewer by
the way what does it mean in Arabic uh
cockroach cockroach cockroach okay I
like you had to think for a second
cockroach okay so let's talk about this
woman because she's become a hero of the
left I see Bernie tweeting uh you know I
stand with Linda I've seen people like
Van Jones claiming that her critics are
bigots she she really does not like you
I mean she's she had a tweet from a
couple years ago that was genuinely
threatening you if you if you were to
live in her city which maybe we'll we'll
put the tweet up and then she tweeted
perhaps the most vile thing that I've
seen on Twitter which was something to
the effect of that she would take away
that women like you like Brigitte and
ayaan Hirsi Ali don't deserve their
vaginas and that she would take them
away now of course she knows that I on
his underwent female genital mutilation
that I on has lived her whole life to
defend the Western principles that
you're talking about here so this is
pretty obvious to anyone that knows
anything about this it's clear to me
what she's doing she does not care about
these women's organizations and yet
she's lauded as a hero of the women's
rights movement while they're out there
in vagina hats what is going on here
Linda Sarsour is a very smart woman I
have to give her that because she is a
master manipulator knowing exactly how
to manipulate the gullible to advance
her cause Linda Sarsour once Sharia law
if it was appeared to be the law of the
land in the United States as a matter of
fact she tweeted many times Alicia about
how wonderful Sharia law is how lucky
women in Saudi Arabia to live under
Sharia law just because they have
maternity leave much better than us did
you see the response from the Israeli
ambassador or something is brilliant she
said talking about how well under Sharia
law in Saudi Arabia they have three
months maternity leave the Israeli
ambassador wrote back he said well our
women have four months and they can
drive yeah but what she doesn't mention
is that these women in Saudi Arabia yeah
they may have maternity leave but they
were the were they impregnate
by consensual sex or were they raped by
their husbands were they beaten into
having sex by their husband were they
you know this is where the touchy
subject that Americans don't feel
comfortable talking about even on
television or radio or anywhere I think
we can be more open even talking on the
internet because this is an Internet
show where we can actually talk about
you know semi truths we can't even be
too open but we're gonna Saudi Arabia
are nothing but chattel that's what the
Quran talks about women women are
secondhand they're there
the hadith says women are like your
field plow into them as if you plow into
your field treat them like barn animals
the Quran looks at women as a material
object to you to be used for pleasure
and to be used to take care of the
household of the clean basically a woman
is a servant a cleaner a factory for
making babies and taking care of the
babies that's it and supplying the
pleasure for for the husband the husband
can divorce her by saying three words
your divorce or divorce or divorce and
that such is divorced no papers required
the women have no right a woman's
testimony testimony is worth half of
that of a man so this is the type of
world that Linda Sarsour want women in
the United States to live under but but
the gullible women's movement in the
United States who came out they hate the
conservative movement so much because
the conservative movement is shining a
light on what Islam is all about and
because they have gone out of their way
to defend everything on the left and the
Islamic agenda that in order for them to
start even looking at what Sharia law is
and how women are treated would
basically make them liars with egg on
their face that they have fought
actually to protect this rights so they
just ignore it completely they'll talk
about it so when you see at the women's
March these women wearing the hijab or
this that picture of the girl in the
niqab you know in an American flag niqab
which I I've mentioned this before I was
in West Hollywood a couple weeks ago
which is quite literally the gayest
place on earth and there was a bunch of
gay guys that sell mannequins and the
one they were all naked except the one
they had dressed was it was the niqab
and I thought you guys you're in the
gayest place on earth the free
this place on earth to do whatever you
want with your life and your fetishizing
something that would that would
undermine your entire life if you
destroy your my god you see the hijab at
the at the women's March and all that
and knowing what you came from it must
absolutely enrage you
oh it's very sad it saddens me because
when I see what the American public is
trying to sell our daughters and our
future generations as acceptable without
recognizing the ramification of it
because Americans are not seeing the
ramification when you start seeing a job
popping into a community that's a sign
of radicalization that's not a sign of
progressiveness it's a sign of going
backward that's actually the first sign
of a radicalization of a community
because that means they're becoming more
devout more following the Quran to the
letter oppressing women and woman in a
hijab means you are shameful to look at
you are dirty to look at therefore you
need to be covered because you are a
walking sin so if I am tempted to look
at you or to rape you you made me rape
you because you made me see your ankle
because it flashed a little bit under
the hijab and therefore you deserve to
be raped or you deserve to be beaten or
you deserve to be abused
what message are we sending our
daughters yeah so you basically think
that there's there's malicious intent
with Saur Saur herself but basically the
the other groups the the day groups and
the women's groups and these other
progressive groups they're just being
they just don't know what they're doing
they don't know what I think they just I
would assume some of them do have bad
intentions I think but I would argue
that most of them just don't even
understand this this alliance that
ultimately will eat itself you can't say
you're for Muslims and for gay people if
those people have competing things now I
would hope that most of them would
forget any of their prejudices and just
live together the idea of where for this
group in this group it grows out all of
the individuals right we've got to be
able to look at the problem we are
facing as a society we all came to
America America is a melting pot we all
came from all over the world we came
here because we loved everything America
stands for you know I'm a
disagree with this person passionately I
may disagree with Linda Sarsour
passionately but I will fight to the
death to make sure that she has the
right to say what she needs to say even
though it makes my skin crawl
she has the right to do that and look at
me I I can't even speak on college
campuses I mean the last college campus
I spoke at was the University of Detroit
at Ann Arbor I had to have nine security
officers and a k-9 unit to sniff the
auditorium for bombs an hour before I
spoke yeah and that's not American
University all right you want to find a
university we can go to together can you
imagine you and I on the road
conservatives national security experts
and you as a gay conservative on
national security people you know don't
expect people like us to come out and
stand for what we believe in and that is
the protection of our country that's
what we care about people are welcome to
come here pray to whatever God they want
build whatever house of worship they
want we are all for that our
Constitution gives them the right to do
that I don't care what rocks you believe
in as long as you don't throw those
rocks at me wanting to kill me yeah you
know that's what America is all about so
we need to shine a light on the problems
and we need our people all Americans to
develop the backbone to start saying
let's step back and look at the problem
that's threatening all of us under
Sharia law gays are thrown off of
buildings women are stoned to death
women are whipped uh you know if they
are seen kissing a man or if they are
impregnated out of wedlock or whatever
the case may be women are forced to
marry women are allowed to be raped and
even in their marriages is this really
what we want in our society a woman can
be raped and she needs four witnesses
to basically for the judge to agree with
her that she actually was raped for male
witnesses and by the way we are seeing
this leak into Western society just in
the last couple weeks there's been a
bunch of stories about for the first
time people are being arrested because
of FGM here in the United States that's
right yeah that's on the protest front
now protests in and of itself is fine
but how is this all connected to what's
happening with the left like this need
to silence everybody so there for
someone like you to not be able to go to
a college campus what is that I mean
that list for you knowing from where you
came there's got to be pretty scary
thought it is a scary thought because I
value freedom because I come from
tyranny I know what it's like to be
muzzled and not be able to say what you
need to say let's you be killed where I
come from any country in the Middle East
I don't care how liberal it is Jordan
Egypt so I'm gonna give you the top two
liberal countries in the Middle East
Jordan in Egypt yeah if you say anything
against the king or you demonstrate
against the king or you don't agree with
something against whatever leader you
are literally rounded on the street
corner and thrown in jail period your
family will never hear from you again
you are tortured you are beaten you are
raped you are sodomized whatever it is
nobody will come to your aid
and that's Jordan in Egypt so I
understand how valuable it is to be able
to come together and demonstrate and
protest and express our opinion freely
and we are losing that in our country
and the irony is we are losing that
because the left who supposedly stands
for tolerance and multiculturalism and
open-mindedness and fairness are
muzzling our speech to be able to say
what we need to say and let people
decide for themselves right because your
story should be a story that the left
would love because you are dark-skinned
yeah you've come from oppression you
know you're a feminist in that you are I
don't have you can or a woman your for
yourself and other women okay but all of
those things they should love your story
and by the way what you're saying about
about Jordan we just did a fan show
where I interviewed 20 people from all
over the world and I interviewed a
bisexual guy in Jordan who was happy to
show his face he said there are there
are gay bars there and he said the one
thing that you can't he said he's not
you know fully out out like that yeah he
said that the real risk is that it's not
that you would say something about the
government's that you'd say something
about the monarchy which is exactly what
you just said so so I just rating that
just cause I said you're not you're not
exaggerating here you're mad on the
point no I mean and those are the
government when you look at the Middle
East you can identify I mean now things
are changing but back up until ten years
ago when you look at the Middle East
you're looking at tribes with flags
those countries with we call countries
its tribes with flags
you can identify every country by one
royal family and or one dictator Saudi
Arabia the royal family Jordan the royal
family Syria Assad Iraq used to be
Saddam Hussein I mean a [ __ ] Tabarrok
before him was Sadat I mean literally
yeah every country by one royal family
which is basically the government and so
we need to protect freedom of speech in
America it is the most valuable thing we
have because they're losing it in Canada
they lost it in Canada yeah they are
losing it all over the world and we
cannot allow what's happening in Europe
to happen in our country that's why I
launched act for America my organization
we are now the largest national security
grassroots movement in the United States
with over half a million members and
over 1,000 chapters nationwide era and I
encourage people who are watching to
join us become active become involved
our members are Christians Jews atheist
Buddhist in those gays lesbians people I
guess you got in there - oh yeah yeah
absolutely and we have moderate Muslim
speak at our national conference every
year of course the left never covers
that you know but we are people who are
bringing Americans together and we're
having the march on June 10th coming up
it's a march against Sharia hashtag
march against Sharia and we already have
17 cities scheduled to have this March
and we haven't even announced it I'm
actually the first place I speak about
and we want people because it coincides
with the shooting at the Orlando against
the gay club it also now with FGM we are
calling FGM months the month of May to
shine a light on what's happening in the
country for half a million girls in
America are subjected and under the
danger of undergoing female genital
mutilation according the CDC either have
gone or are their risk of going the
female genital mutilation and the
feminists and the left you simply won't
actually said meanwhile a conservative
right-wing maniac is gonna is going to
die
right but we are organizing these
marches anybody who wants to get
involved and March with us go to our
website x4 america.org send us an email
put march against Sharia and get
involved for more information in your
city so do you see the best way to
counter this is purely just the free
speech thing I mean we can
we can talk about the ins and outs all
the time and we can try to expose people
like Sarsour and and the rest of this
but that truly that the sword that we
all have to die on is the free-speech
thing is that really the the only answer
to this it's the only answer that I can
come up with which is why I do this show
the way I do it but a free speech and
activism our side doesn't act they sit
around and say oh my god our side
doesn't show up and demonstrate our side
doesn't show up and really come together
to show any show of force by presence
you know show up on the streets the left
shows up by the thousands the tens of
thousands we go a rally you see a
hundred people show up we need more
people showing up we need more people
active and engaged and that's why we
named the organization act for America
now think about America and hope for
America not wish for America but act for
America because without action nothing
happens we have a national conference
coming up in Washington DC October I
encourage people to go to our website
and find out more information about it
act con 2017 our National Conference we
have 16 members of Congress every year
speak at our national conference
it's the largest gathering of Americans
of all background meeting with elected
officials coming on Washington DC to
remind elected officials national
security is important we are fighting
for the preservation of our
judeo-christian culture where everybody
can be free everybody can do whatever
they want to do as long as they respect
the Constitution and agree that everyone
is equal under the law yeah it's
interesting to me that you make that
distinction that you're talking about
judeo-christian culture but what you're
really asking for is that we just be
governed by our laws you're not being
you're not and there's I think a lot of
people even atheists have a struggle
with this the idea that our foundation
sort of is judeo-christian but you're
not you're not asking that anyone be
governed under the Old Testament or a
purely cultural purely secular when you
look at Western civilization Western
civilization was founded on
judeo-christian principles the holding
the Ten Commandments call them
principles you know do unto others what
you want others to do unto you we are
raised with that whether we're
practicing Christians or not
my children were raised without the
mention of God in my household complete
atheists they didn't know anything about
the Bible they didn't know I didn't have
a Bible in the household nothing my
children were raised with do unto others
what you want others to do unto you be
kind forgive your enemy forgive those
who trespass against so you're above
holding a crutch move forward and lies
just release some focus on the good make
good focus your energy on making the
world a better place
those are judeo-christian principles yes
they are founded in the Bible but they
are judeo-christian principles that
everybody in the Western world lives and
abides by and we are truly facing a
clash of cultures right now yeah
so speaking of a clash of cultures I
thought I'd do you a little favor here
because when I was doing research about
you if I look at your Wikipedia not that
I trust I mean I don't trust anyone's
Wikipedia but there is this constant
theme that you're somehow anti-muslim
that you're an anti-muslim bigotry that
effect so I thought I would give you the
chance to say something about Muslim
people I know you make the distinction
between Islam as a set of ideas you've
already you know briefly mention this
and the people but if you say something
publicly maybe we can counter a little
of the Wikipedia cuz I don't sense
bigotry from you I sense someone that's
fighting for values consistently whether
the bad ideas were coming from Jews or
Christians or wherever else no so let's
clean it up and you know Wikipedia you
know anybody can say anything they want
to Romania so never ever believe
Wikipedia because it's a bunch of lies
we talk to them we try to change the
profile they will go back immediately
some leftist and they will change it
back to whatever they want to frame see
they're trying to frame people like you
and me in a certain way this is the war
of ideas right now and they are trying
to smear our reputation by coming up
with their own language I am NOT anti
Muslim I am anti ideology that wants to
kill Free People and subjugate them in
the name right now in the name of the
Islamic religion I know I would fight
with the same passion if crazy
Christians were trying to do that or
crazy Jews were trying to do that or
whatever crazy religion is trying to do
that I am for the human spirit and the
individuality of the human spirit I am
the perfect example of a woman who was
raised
a bomb shelter if feminists who came to
America is living the American dream
started their own business I am all I
can be as a person and trying to be
better and trying to make the world a
better place I love people there are
Muslims in this world who do not want to
have anything to do with the radicals do
not want to kill anywhere anybody have
never even read the Koran I don't give
you this day I'll tell you this my
daughter just had a baby
my daughter named her baby Lila
after her Muslim best friend so my
granddaughter is named after her Muslim
best friend who was with us on Easter
Sunday just a couple weeks ago baptizing
my grandchild and who is from Pakistan
so you tell me am ia racist or hates all
Muslims which is absolute nonsense you
know but this is how the left is
attacking us the best thing we can do is
move forward doing what we do work with
moderate Muslims who love the West as
much as we do we'll love our values as
much as we do who love our culture as
much as we do and work together to
defend our culture against the radicals
who want to kill us all
yeah do you think that there's something
particularly perverse with the left now
like for someone like me that's kind of
only in this for the last couple years
and I I used to be a progressive and
then I saw what was going on
does it seem worse to you now or am I
just kind of new to this over the last
couple years like ten years ago do you
think it was this this bad or the
orgeous that the plans maybe hadn't kind
of kicked in it was bad but it has
gotten worse because it was bad but it
was not this violent and maybe because
they had Obama in office and so they
didn't realize it because people on the
right on this specific issue I'm not
gonna go out and smash windows and break
windows because I don't disagree with
the speaker when Obama was elected I
didn't agree with Obama but I respected
him for the position that he held and I
said okay here's our president we're
gonna give him a chance and what an
amazing country we live in that we were
able to elect a black president this is
a testimony about how Great America is I
actually cried and I did not vote for
Obama but I had tears in my eyes
watching the results of the election
even though it was a mixed emotion of
sadness but at the same time joy that we
as a great nation were able to put our
differences aside and be able to elect
despite the history a black president
and we said you know what we're gonna
give him the best shot you didn't see
people like me demonstrating breaking
windows so the left right now is so
intolerant is so vicious and their
attacks to the point that if you or me
or Milo or Ann Coulter or I am here see
Ellie say anything about anything we are
attacked physically no and that's a
shame that we are to this point in our
country all right so just a couple other
things and then we're gonna do one bonus
segment with you that part of it that
you've put yourself out there publicly
and that people say bad things or that
you've had to have police take here at a
university or whatever it is can you
just talk about the cost of that I know
I know every public person doesn't like
talking about it but there is a cost and
I can see as you sit here and smiling
and how passionate you are about all of
this stuff that it's not something you
focus on but because I think people ask
me about that a lot you know like what
about putting yourself out there people
are afraid to do it but my feeling is we
need more people I don't think I'm
anyone special I'm one guy that's doing
something that I believe in but for you
just the cost of they history remembers
those who made a difference and I
believe every single one of us in life
has a destiny has a purpose and every
single one of us in life is shaped by
the experiences that we go through and
every experience is a preparation every
experience is a stepping stone to refine
us so we can be instruments of change as
adults in our world to make the world a
better place
some of us recognize their purpose and
some of us live a lifetime without ever
recognizing their purpose but if you do
recognize your purpose and you are
fortunate enough to realize the gifts
that you have been given even though you
have gotten these gifts through going
through hell like I did I know that
is my opportunity to be able to speak
for my nation and make a difference I
emigrated to the land of the free and
the home of the brave and I wake up
every morning and I thank God that our
founding fathers that I can fight
sitting in my pajamas in front of my
computer and don't have to brave the
snow and Valley Forge the way our
founding fathers suffered and starved
and froze and some of them died broke
giving their life up putting their life
on the line to give us the freedoms that
we have today the least we can do is
preserve those freedoms for our next
generation you never really own freedom
David we only take care of freedom and
preserve it to the next generation
and I am doing my part as an American as
a brave American and the home of the
brave to make sure I follow in the
footsteps of our founding fathers and do
my part as they entrusted me with that
which they have created I feel it is my
duty to make sure to preserve it to pass
it to my children and their American
children and many generations to come
that's why we fight and I am so
fortunate that through this fight and it
is a fight for freedom for liberty for
democracy for security for human rights
I am privileged to meet the most amazing
people that I would never otherwise meet
like sitting here with you today
and meet friends that have become
lifelong friends literally like family
to me that I would never have otherwise
met if it wasn't doing for what I do so
do I get depressed
doing what I do talking about terrorism
and national security of course I do I'm
human like everybody sometimes I cry
sometimes I'm completely depressed over
things that are happening sometimes I
hurt deeply by people who stab me in the
back or say bad things about me or even
reading my Wikipedia profile but what
keeps me so energized is the American
people and the American spirit knowing
that we are making a difference we are
growing we are changing our country we
are fighting we have a purpose so when
you and I die on our deathbed we can
look back and we can
say I made a difference as we take our
last breaths and that's enough for me
well I actually had a couple more
questions for you back that is how you
end an interview we're gonna do a little
more for our for our patreon audience
and I thank you for this this is a
pleasure especially the end I'm feeling
very energized for more on Brigitte and
her work it's that the lights are
getting me from where I'm Brigitte and
her work check out act for America
[Music]
you